when people found out that like we
weren't close friends they got so upset
they're mad at something that we're not
even mad about if you look at two
professional athletes and they work
professionally but they're not friends
how is Michael Jordan not friends with
Scottie bit like Jill hi they see us
laughing they see us having this
chemistry and they don't recognize as
comedians it's just what we do like I
can sit down with any comedian even if
they not my friends not any commute but
most can i yeah but you know I mean like
you mean that you get along with but
you're not friends with you know I'm
saying and you guys start chopping it up
and it's just natural yeah that's what
we do is have we been doing them
consistently for like four years so I'm
gonna have that concern random condition
yeah it's not because you enjoy success
together you necessarily have to be
friends I think I've sent you that
article from Cristiano Ronaldo he knows
a video it's a video I saw it I saw it
okay glad you said it to me I was like
what's the point yeah but then you
understood what yeah and Ronaldo
attended the press conference in Rome
this evening and he was asked about
Messi Suarez and Neymar being good
friends whereas Bale Benzema and
Cristiano don't appear to be as time
well if you say so
what do you want me to say they look a
little Eve what you read or what you
hear so you know that's true literacy
vocalist wash could he was a minister no
but I'm going to tell him something
for example munch in Manchester we won
the Champions League I didn't used to
chat with skulls Giggs and Ferdinand on
the pitch we had a brilliant team Ethan
amazonite you bushed up in there
I love him still a lot that normal
things like good morning how are you
this doesn't mean anything that'll
convince them I don't have to have
dinner with fight Bale round to my house
isn't the most important event of the
company the most important thing is what
happens on the pitch with my team we
know what we want we know how to play
dinner's out hugs and kisses for me
doesn't mean a thing
the most important thing is what happens
on the pitch and that the team wins the
follow me that's what really matters
porno is is it Michael that players
well does it matter really mmm I think
he sees things very professional I mean
it's it's it in the end it's a job of
course football is very specific and
we've seen each other more than maybe
our wives or girlfriends because we are
all day in day out we're together with
traveling you know the problem is your
teammates would you have gone out with
that was a player who had my own
friendship as well outside outside the
pitch so I've seen the players a lot and
if the training is over the game is over
you want to have a private life as well
and you have to accept that players go
different ways of course there are good
relationships between players but not
all of them are huge friends I mean
that's that's known as I make a good
team I think you have to have that
respect if you mites as well
you're gonna jail you're not going to
jail with 30 lads or whatever 25 lads
but you have to have that respect for
each other because talking about that I
don't have to is be winning on the field
yeah if we're winning on the field and
I'm good after that we don't need to bug
in or whatever little cordial and we're
good we get along but once it's time to
work that we do what we need to do
that's what matters
well this is that seems yeah but we chop
it up we eat whatever but it's not like
a everyday thing where we lean on me
yeah no but it's just funny to me the
here the theories Oh ever since they
announced that they were friends I just
felt like they've been different with
each other and this is why I always
laugh who are you the reason why when
people say they feel some things I'm
like yeah I know it's really just in
your head you know I mean
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's what he doesn't think I thought
lies just yeah anyways whatever all that
to say you have to understand that
you're only catching only the
information that you have which is a
small percentage of our days this that
you have here even if you see us once a
day for like since the beginning of
January it's just a small percentage of
our lives and you blaze the rest of our
lives on just a small percentage that
you have no more things to say you know
you don't know the days of our lives
yeah sometimes you do that to me it's
like if I base myself off like what the
videos are worth like the majority like
nine minutes around that it's like if I
base myself on what your life would be
if I just base it on the nine first
minutes of where you wake up damn is
that no it's just nine minutes of the
day it's a small percentage so you can't
base yourself for what you see and
that's why people put people on
pedestals yeah when you see people on
Instagram it's just a small percentage
of their day you just see them like you
just see their wins and not pose they're
a lot like them losing they post a
caption of themselves on a beach and
you're just like I don't think Cindy's
having a good week you just saw a
ten-second Instagram story that ain't
nothing here's the irony is that when
you guys thought we were at her best
which was like two three years ago
that's actually we had the most
turbulence between each other right now
we're in the best place possible that
was yeah it was probably everything was
a struggle everything everything was a
comedy was a struggle our relationship
was a struggle the YouTube stuff was a
struggle now things as you like it right
you guessed it every time was a thing in
the show like that so and people also
have to recognize were comedians we
oblivion set of rules in terms of how
our relationship works you know
how I talk with other comedians is not
how I talk with regular civilians no
it's just not and so what you guys
interpret as some kind of friendship and
deep-rooted relationship is actually how
comics talk
if you've ever sat in the green room
with comics who like each other and
they're really good at shooting the [ __ ]
it looks just like this I can assure you
every time we run our shows and we have
a green room isn't it I like how we talk
right now yeah yeah pretty much yeah you
know your good friend Dan I don't know
nothing about him it was just an agree
we weren't in the same stage together
but I don't know nothing about that very
certain actions between people mean
different things pretty stuff those
people I see parents who kiss their kids
that's gross to me you kiss your killing
lip that's nasty in some places
that's just familial love in other
places like Alabama that's incest I get
it it means different things be soft who
doesn't so messy let's put it out there
still nasty put to the people who kiss
their kids on lipping is just cool
that's just something y'all gotta keep
in mind you don't know us you don't have
a good grasp of what we're like and
we're comedians this is how we live and
you're just basing yourself off a small
percentage of our lives it's just
fascinating to see how off people's
intuition is but I was I don't want to
stick on this too long heard that like
like he doesn't get to be his Ross okay
hold on who is my rostov [ __ ] they know
you better than you know yourself
apparently
[Music]
we get mad they but ABBA why are you
looking at your phone while preaches
talking why though I don't make me
realize this is no but you got all your
points what do you mean that's what you
got all your points that's where you
have your pointers no this is where we
play the video yeah I know the video and
where you got your point sometimes you
read off the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah sometimes
I read up like articles play it
sometimes I'd be laughing at the
comments because they don't know they
they be reading into stuff it's funny to
watch
I felt like preach had more to say and
I'm just like okay we're after gonna get
to a point very soon where we stop
reading all day I'm there yeah
congratulations
I need to get there I read the comments
while watching the video cuz I know what
I said and everything and stuff yeah
what's up I saw the video once I'm not
gonna reread the comments you know I'm
gonna re-watch videos too sometimes some
of them are you know really really
really funny like it get at me like you
to that house you watch it but that
video makes you like eels me let me get
let me get the juice let me let me go
get some juice Matt you know but other
than that I don't really read comments I
stop I I start rereading comments or
reading comments when we did that video
two years ago about two years ago when
Donald Trump said [ __ ] a little country
oh yeah I'm and then you tagged Donald
Trump and in all his supporters was
calling us all sorts his name but it
really started when we did a video when
you ask the question if a woman yeah I
let the woman choose what should we pay
you know I know exactly and then and
then people like the death threats and
stuff like that and I start reading then
it's also funny because they might be
reading stuff and they'd be like you
know a book cut off preach when he was
singing this and added I have a look so
pissed where's ABBA looking off of honey
there's a guy that wrote you know when
you speak preach what do you look what
do you look at I look at my thoughts I'm
thinking I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
look at the cat got it I got it
Instagram is just a small percentage of
their day you just see them